good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
tuesday hope everyone is having a
fabulous spectacular day um
i mean it's a little early to call it
that perfect response
um no same i'm having a terrible day but
that's why
um you want to actually it's a fabulous
question you asked i'm sorry
i'm really i have no idea i'm so glad
you brought it up whatever you're gonna
say
i've been kind of re-hauling my makeup
um routine my skincare routine
i've just what else is there to do other
than like take care of myself and feel
good about myself
and you know when you wake up and like
you have new makeup and you're like
low-key like excited to do your makeup
more so than the average day it's
something different yeah and i got like
new
cream contour from fenty beauty that
they didn't have in store i had to wait
online like i was just excited about it
and some i just i woke up like grimy and
crusty and and nothing helped you know
and it's like disappointing to go from
like the excitement of
potential to just realizing like new
makeup
same shitty life yeah you know yeah no
that is that's a tough fall speaking of
uh new faces uh do i look different oh
my god you actually do i'm gonna do a
full inspection um after the show i
would love to see
but jackie shaved her watch i was
influenced by you the influencer
to dermaplane my face aka shave the
fotch
and i'm not sure so i think ultimately i
didn't go hard enough
because there wasn't that much hair
coming off on the blade but
i'm glad to start at that place rather
than like cutting up my face from going
too hard so i'm just getting comfortable
with the movement
but it was really interesting to do like
a whole face haul yesterday because i
used like clarifying pads and like serum
and oil
because i followed i think i watched the
same videos because we both watched from
the morning toast youtube account and i
saw where you
where you dropped off that's my favorite
thing that we like share a youtube
account and like when it goes to the
videos you're in the middle of like i
actually don't see a lot of yours but i
watch so much youtube do you see my
weird like james charles stuff
yeah no i see i pretty much i get what
you get but only on my
ipad am i logged into that account so
it's not all the time
but yes i shaved the thotch and i do
feel like it definitely
let my makeup set better but i don't
know about anyone else my skin
is breaking out like crazy and it's just
around like my chin
and my mouth and i think it's from the
masks well if you had told me that i
would have told you
not to shave your thoughts because they
say it can be so fabulous but the only
real downfall is like if you have
breakouts or you have acne prone skin
and like you're going through it with
the acne
shaving your face is the worst thing you
can do because it irritates it well i
didn't really
shave it like my chin okay which is
where i'm breaking out the most i did
like my
my sideburns yeah peach fuzz yeah the
peach fuzz yeah i tried to i avoided any
like hot zone areas but you got to clean
your masks people because i think a
dirty mask
is giving me pimples 1 000 dirty towels
can give you pimples
dirty pillowcase 100 so that's
definitely a possibility and i only
recently like realized like i could and
should be washing my masks
so i threw them me and ben like we leave
them all on our front door knob
because like you grab one before you
leave and i threw it in with a tide pod
which i guess a tide pod is made for
like a full load of laundry not like
six small pieces of cloth no it's not
and it could give you a rash like then
you'll end up with a new problem
literally i put the mask on fresh out of
laundry i couldn't breathe i was like
breathing in toxins it was
it smelled good but it was so
overwhelming so insane to do i know it
was
crazy yeah okay you learned your lesson
maybe i would do it in the laundry again
with no tide pod just like water is that
weird
put it in with all your clothes yeah
yeah yeah and then you know
disperse the pod i've really pretty much
exclusively been wearing our toast masks
which
not to pit masks against one another but
is truly the best in the game and i hate
to say that because like they're not
even for sale because like they're
sold out so sorry to be annoying but the
size is so perfect and when i washed it
it did not shrink
and it's just really like the best mask
on the market dare i say
yeah maybe i need to be switching up
wearing my toastmaster more because it
does give you a little breathing room
which is nice
so i i definitely need to figure out my
mask situation because i thought my
masks were clean i got makeup on them
but
i wear them like one day but i guess i
need to figure that part out because
these pimples are just not going to work
for me
no you could also i guess like wash them
in your sink with like wool like how you
do hanky pankies you know yeah that's
true but i just when
i just throw them in the laundry and
when i do the laundry masks come out
it's like a
it really is a new category you know
it's like i need a draw
drawer for my masks there was actually
like a tick tock trend going around like
show me where you leave your masks and
like how you organize them and it was
actually
really interesting i just started to
like gather them because we take theo
out so
ben takes video out so many times a day
that like to go rummaging through your
purse every time you need a mask it's
not ideal leaving them by the front door
if you have like a
a mud room you put it on a hook like
you're actually thinking of maybe like
getting some hooks
oh that's smart i get i have a few by
the front door just in case i didn't
plan my mask to my outfit
and then i have a few like in my makeup
area um
it just depends it just depends that's
the thing about life
life just depends it just depends um
also a different change in me that i was
wondering if anyone would notice wait
let me see let me see
can you give me a region of your body
steal your potch no okay
um okay you're not no i have no idea
so my shoes do you recognize these shoes
yes you have them in white and you got a
lot of [ __ ] because you would literally
exclusively wore them for the entire two
years we were at the old studio yes and
i still only wear them and i know people
are extremely triggered by them and
that's not what i'm trying to do here
so i got them in another color that i
think are a little um
less glaring you know they're
salmon yeah they're like they they're
called light pink but this is not like
no that's like that is actually like
looking up at the dictionary the color
salmon like that's what it is yeah
so i feel like it's better it's not like
the stark white shoes when they don't
really match the outfit even though you
guys know i love those shoes
so that's something that's something new
with me that is exciting i'm so happy
for you
yeah um if you're watching on youtube
today and you might notice my legs it's
i've taken some time off from spray
tanning them or using self-tanning
self-stand because i'm actually getting
a spray tan tomorrow today today that's
exciting
very exciting for the first time in
months so like you're gonna catch me
tomorrow out here like literally wearing
you know denim underwear because i'm
just gonna be so thrilled about my new
tan legs
that's really exciting so i did
something last night because you posted
that video
uh the clip from yesterday's show that
had me on the floor crying laughing
tears in my eyes
um so i was like just looking on our
feed for other funny videos because we
do that once in a while we post
highlights from the show and i saw some
videos from like the first week of
quarantine
and it made me so upset those are
different girls
oh yeah our spirit has been broken no
our spirit has been broken
i knew that it was bad but i didn't
realize how bad it had gotten
and you know that first week or two of
quarantine was actually very exciting
because like it wasn't like the
coronavirus has just like broken
everyone it's just
devastated the entire world on so many
different levels but at that time it was
like a
like we got like a one week vacation and
we didn't know how many implications
there would be obviously like on our
country
but we just thought we were like wow
this is crazy like this is
time we're never gonna get back let's
and it just it turned into something so
much different than i really thought it
was going to be
no it's crazy if you had told that girl
like we had a clip where i was like
what's the first thing you're going to
do when you're back and
we just had so much energy so exciting
and it's like now i don't even want to
do those what's that
no totally yeah that is depressing
it was really it was eye-opening i just
had gotten so far deep in the hole i
didn't even realize that's what we do
here at the morning toast we open eyes
yeah we realize things we realize things
um major uh update which i'm sure we'll
talk about
but a story we like weirdly broke
yesterday yes we're gonna talk about it
vanessa morgan
should we get into it um yeah i have a
little tv to recap i started the new
season of shameless so i want to talk
about that
i finished season two of yellowstone i
think season three is airing right now
so i need to go
find a way to find the episodes it is so
good i know i'm highly recommending it
to you
and you're just not taking my
recommendation by the way i'm
it is definitely on my very short list
of things to watch but like
i spoke to you like five times yesterday
and truly every time i spoke to you you
were like you should watch yellowstone
making me think that like you literally
have equity in the show and like your
its success is
on your back you know what i have equity
in your happiness that's very sweet
and theos and i know he he wants to know
what happened
well we're gonna finish i mean we're
gonna start it's really really good
and it's it's so good so um once you
watch them we can probably do an
in-depth recap
yeah i'm just like i'm still in the
phase where i just really can't watch tv
i just need to listen to folklore like
that's still where i'm at oh my god i
did something so soothing last night
and i cooked a home chef meal with my
air pods in listening to folklore wow
and it was just i i can't recommend a
cooking and a folklore
and i was really able to pay attention
please
to all of the lyrics it is so good i've
really only done one full pass through
the album before
aside from listening to cardigan it was
playing on the radio card again the
other one
um and all of the songs even though i've
only heard them once or twice are
already so familiar
yes of course yes yes it's really
something
you know what i did yesterday that you
actually might enjoy and i thought this
is what you were gonna say
i actually want my apples to be put on
the youtube lyric videos
because they're beautiful like each song
just pictures like a different landscape
there's like a beach and a rainy forest
and then the lyrics pop up and it's just
a easy way to like see what she's saying
and it was very soothing very like asmr
almost and i really enjoyed it and
that's
yesterday i think i really i knew the
album but i feel like i
got into bed with it literally and i've
pretty much established my favorite
songs okay yeah have they changed since
yesterday
um i think yesterday i just really
breathed on saying that peace is
so good when it's probably my top two
wow
yeah and i think it's one it's towards
the end that people just kind of
like lump together with hoax but it is a
true lyrical masterpiece like it's and
the the premise of the song i think is
about joe because it's like talking
about how
in no uncertain terms like is this the
man for her but would it be enough if
she could never give him peace like her
life is so
not peaceful like it's very um
tumultuous at times and living in the
spotlight has obviously its privileges
but also its disadvantages
and i think that like part of her like
feels guilty that like she kind of
plucked joe from obscurity and like gave
him this
burden in in a lot of ways and it's just
a beautiful song
wow and then there's of course you know
we had to decode you know about how life
is so crazy there's robbers to the east
and clowns to the west
and west is capitalized in the lyrical
video with a capital w
which um obviously you know me as the
resident
person in the middle on taylor vs kanye
it was really hard for me to see that
lyric
it was the robber in the east no i think
it was just like a metaphor like there's
crazy things all around us but she took
the west opportunity to you know say
something
to yeah make a statement got it okay you
learned something new about folklore
every day truly i'm still spending a lot
of time dissecting this
love triangle between betty august and
cardigan
betty is very easy to understand it's
literally like betty says this i said
that i did this to betty
but august and cardigan which are
allegedly parts of this love story
love triangle um are a little harder to
dissect and that's why i went on and
watched the lyric videos it was really
enjoyable but also very helpful
interesting i had a thought sort of
expanding on something we talked about
yesterday
yesterday about the potential music
video for august and we were talking how
it needs to like be a recreation of a
90s movie
but i think it should be like exactly
like wildest dreams but the set of a 90s
movie
you know wildest streams music video is
a true work like they're working on this
movie on location and it's
this romantic glamorous old hollywood
love story and they need to be
working on a movie on location of 10
things i hate about you
and then like at the end they go from
the movie in love to like real life and
love yeah that's a very good idea i mean
i think wildest dreams for
that music video is first of all the
most visually stunning thing i've ever
seen in my life and so well done and of
course
scott eastwood just helps sickening
sickening like really really good that's
a good idea i like that
thank you yeah um and then so taylor
usually does
an album and then a deluxe version at
target
right she's had this deluxe like
partnership with target forever and
there's always like a few
um deluxe songs and they're some of my
favorite songs it's crazy that like
to me i think some of her best songs new
romantics was like not even everyone
heard that like it was literally on a
target cd
that's crazy to me because that's just
part of the album to me but a song that
i just discovered that apparently was
from a deluxe was
come back stay here yeah that's a deluxe
song
i just it's like it's actually exciting
it's like taylor drop new music you know
what else i think is a deluxe song
you can hear it in the silence silence
silence silence
which is crazy um and then one more
thing i wanted to say oh
so about the lakes so the lakes are
referenced in um
one of the songs about joe the one and
it's like we spent the
summer at the lakes and so now there's
all these series that when the lakes
come out comes out
it's some sort of announcement related
to joe perhaps
and give you peach he says i want to
give you my wild give you a child
um so people think maybe she's married
engaged and this happens every time but
there is substantial evidence to believe
that when the lakes comes out and it
only comes out when people get their
deluxe cds
shipped which should be august like
seven you know some of the numbers add
up to 13 or whatever
um that it would be like x amount of
time
since she was months i don't know but i
just want to put it out there because
it's very possible that a tailor-related
announcement could be coming via the
lakes
got it i love the name of the lakes for
a song me too i personally
think they're already married and if
they're not already married marriage
isn't
on the table like they're just forever
life partners
not you know yeah they don't need to
take the step of marriage well that's
the thing it's like when you're as
successful as taylor swift marriage is
obviously marriage but it's so much more
than that
um and so a lot of people at that level
just like make a commitment to each
other forever that's not marriage but i
also feel like for taylor if you think
about some of her
older songs like she's such a romantic
that marriage
is part of that plan like speak now you
know love story
and i feel like she would say yes to
marriage
i think so too she would just have like
thousands of pages of paperwork for sure
for sure for sure um so that is the
that's your daily folklore update you
can come to expect one every day i guess
until i have a question example comes
out i have a question
would it be enough if i could never give
you peace
would it um sure i was trying to explain
to ben like all these songs you know i'm
like and then she did this
and then taylor says this and then i was
being so annoying like
would it be enough and he was like no
well i mean what is peace even who has
peace
that's that's so true even if you're not
a global superstar and have the set of
problems that comes with that like
everyone has their [ __ ] to deal with so
you might as well get the girl fall in
love
and be happy nobody really has peace to
give
yeah it's very true just a little two
cents
okay um shall we shall we let's jump
right in
we have a lot to cover today into the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
anything to say no okay first story's so
exciting so we need to we absolutely
need to jump right in
sophie turner and joe jonas are
delighted to welcome their first
child i feel like this happens so fast
so fast
maybe that's because she didn't like
bombard us with content like we never
barely even saw her pregnant yeah the
way that this all went down
the timeline was just
it just zoomed right past us totally you
know and i think i don't know at what
point in her pregnancy well they never
announced
but i don't know at one point we found
out at what point did just jared find
out
right right it must have been i mean i
can't do quick math right now but it
must have been kind of far along
yeah like maybe five months in according
to tmz who was the first to report the
birth the couple welcomed a girl named
willa on wednesday july 22nd at los
angeles
los angeles area hospital quote the
couple is already obsessed and can't
stop gloating about their new addition
of source tells entertainment tonight
the couple is taking time to enjoy this
special moment
and have only shared the news and
updates with family and friends i'm
getting choked up
truly a frog in your throat claudia
that's beautiful when i recorded um our
most recent patreon episode with olivia
we were talking about how she really
gave birth during like such an unideal
time
given the pandemic especially in new
york but she's like a new mom at such an
ideal time because there's really
nothing else going on and you can really
like focus
and i feel the same way for sophie
turner like
this is fabulous and she has nowhere to
go no projects to film she just gets to
be home
with her baby yeah it's really beautiful
remember how he used to say that you
know couples
celebrity couples who blame scheduling
conflicts as a reason to break up his
horseshit
considering joe jonas and sophie turner
are able to make it work bless you
right while he was relaunching jonas
brothers and she was starring in the
game of thrones
final season and x-men and now it's like
they made that sacrifice for each other
knowing that their schedules would
conflict but they love each other so
much and they got the greatest gift of
all time which is
time yeah no and i think like they those
were both like major major moments for
them in their career and it just so
happened that they were happening at the
same time
which is great but not ideal for like
schedules
and i feel like they they made the
commitment like we know this is going to
be hard for like the next year but like
after that like we will
make it work around each other's
schedules and i feel like that's what
they really did like after
game of thrones she did that movie and
then she really like went on tour
and did cup of joe with him in a few
episodes like they balance each other
very well
yeah they do and they they're both such
big and bright stars
but they want to see the other shine oh
completely and i just like anytime i
hear them talk about each other like i
get choked up because like
obviously part of me believes like it
should be me out there you know in los
angeles
hospital having his child but also but
also because like they really are a
perfect batch so if it's not gonna be me
like i guess it could be her
um and they have like this such like
this deep like kind of
um like mature love like do you ever see
her episode on the dr phil
i've seen snippets it's such a fabulous
podcast episode i think it's also on
youtube if you want to watch it like dr
phil was in my dream last night
that's weird i think he was wearing a
wig jordan mcgraw on your mind no no
it wasn't a jordan mcgraw-related thing
dr phil was wearing a wig
fabulous yeah it was awesome um but yeah
that episode
she talks a lot obviously about mental
health because that's what really dr
phil does
and then she was talking about how like
her her ongoing struggle with mental
health like was
made a lot easier when joe came into the
picture because like he loved her so
much
and she was like joe jonas like likes me
like i should like me
and i just i love to hear them talk
about like their burgeoning relationship
and now how they feel about each other
and you don't get it a lot you don't get
it a lot no but when you do
it's really pure magic it's pure magic
and now they have
a magical addition to their family baby
makes three baby makes three willa jonas
i just want to say oh wait there's a
name
yeah willa oh got it in here willa spell
it w-i-l-l-a-i-i-e will afford i wanna
be bad
i mean we'll afford i could do a whole
podcast episode on what that song did to
me when her and all of her friends
were dancing in like this garage with
like the smallest shorts i ever saw in
my life and i was literally like
yeah i want to be bad like yeah i don't
even know what that meant like i [ __ ]
love that song and so to be named after
an iconic singer such as willa ford
the baby is truly blessed yeah she's
destined for greatness i really do love
the name
it's crazy that it's a jonas baby you
know
yes it's crazy that her last name is
jonas right like
she'll maybe have a sister and they'll
be the jonas sisters
wow along with the uh jonas
kevin kids yeah and then hopefully you
know nick and pre have
cute sweet little babies if that's what
they want if that's what they want from
themselves
and then we'll have the jonas cousins
well the jay cuz the jay cousins what if
a couple of the cousins were musical and
they started a band called the jonas
cousins
that would be like and then like that's
the music that like god willing our
children
right that would be like an infringement
i think though on that jonas brothers
intellectual property
but like they would they would lend it
to them and you know the jedi's brothers
are notoriously litigious
they would lend it to the children they
would like to they would lend it for
sure
anyways this is really so exciting so
beautiful
just it's just good unexpected news when
i sit back and think about like
where we've how far we've come with the
jonas brothers it honestly
makes me feel old first of all because
like it's very rare to like have
followed someone from like the time
they were your age to like now they're
married and having kids like kind of in
the same
life stage as us and it's just so crazy
like how they've reinvented themselves
like
so wholeheartedly yeah and so many times
and this last time so well yeah
it's been it's been a really interesting
journey for them
yes but i love that they all prioritize
obviously family me too
and marriage love relationships etc 100
the j sisters the j babies the jay
cousins numero uno
cause that's all that matters it's truly
all that matters okay next story a
little sad couple news michael kopech
files for divorce from pregnant
riverdale star vanessa morgan
no is i think the headline says as
predicted by podcast host claudia's
right yes
i was they put in the second half of the
headline after six months of marriage as
predicted by podcast host claudia ashrae
so it's just so funny how like claudia
ashrae
also from my comedy special now
streaming um it's just so funny how like
sometimes here on the show and just like
on forums like twitter
people like fans have the ability to
like snuff things out and sometimes they
are so off and sometimes they are
spot [ __ ] on yeah it's
it's tough because sometimes they're so
spot on it makes you think that all the
times that they were off that there
might have been merit to it
but it's it's almost just like a game of
probability considering how much people
are so off about sometimes
yeah it it has to swing the other way
and this was just one of those times but
i also feel as though
she was being deliberate yes agreed in
her pronoun usage on her instagram post
about her
beautiful baby boy yes so chicago white
sox picture michael kopeck and riverdale
star vanessa morgan
who is currently pregnant with their
first child are parting weights after
six months of marriage
kopec filed divorce in his home state of
texas on june 19th
the chicago tribune reported citing
court records the documents were filed
in morris county and a hearing date was
not listed according to the outlet
a representative for morgan confirmed to
people that kopeck is the father of
morgan's baby
but declined to comment on the divorce
filing a spokesperson for kopeck did not
immediately respond to people's requests
for comment
oh i didn't see that he confirmed
because then people are like [ __ ]
like
coming up with conspiracy theories about
the baby which is so rude so
okay it is michael i mean as far as i
know
you know the very limited research that
i've done is that michael kopeck has
been
kind of um going through some stuff in
the last
year or two he took off this season of
baseball and was injured last season so
that's two consecutive seasons
for someone who was like a shot like a
had a lot of
potential you know and a long future
career
it's very bad to be like off for two
seasons so he obviously
um i think is gonna have to be going
through something
yeah on july third the chicago sun time
said that he was absolutely
what the chicago sun times what's that
from
jackie is it from um never been kissed
yes okay
uh they josie uh the editing managing
editor on this story said
that um he was absent from white sox
camp
because of a personal matter so that's
why
he's not at camp right now because the
mlb like is is back
yeah so yeah it's definitely there's
more to the story it seems
obviously like a personal matter and i
just i wish happiness for both of them
and you know i feel like this is all the
information we're gonna get
yeah and you know what as respectful
people i think it's really all that we
need
it's not our business obviously things
aren't great when
you're married for a short period of
time you get pregnant
and and you and you still don't want to
try to make it work right so
i think we just let bygones be bygones
but um it's just so interesting how like
neither of these two people are like
actually that famous but the story maybe
it was like there was nothing else going
on yesterday but
i saw the story everywhere like places
that didn't even cover that vanessa was
pregnant
i just think that the circumstances are
so odd that it's people are curious
and i think also even though they're
both not that famous
when two stars from like different
worlds come together like now we have
all the sports fans
interested and we have all the riverdale
stands
very popular culture that's true and
that just doubles the pool of people who
might be interested in this
yeah you know i was talking to ben about
sports yesterday i'm just learning so
much because i've been seeing everyone
talk about the bubble do you know what
that is
yes the nfl nba nba
and so ben was saying how he's so
excited for basketball to come back i'm
like
um like did the next get any new players
like are they good
and he's like no they're not even
playing i'm like what
oh because it's based on who was doing
well in the last season no they're just
picking up like right where they stop
which i think is crazy because it's like
the the basketball season would have
premiered like in the next month or two
so it's like why don't we just like
start over yeah it's like you know last
year's irrelevant it's curse like let's
just start over
or or considering it's going to be
fanless games
it's kind of perfect to finish out the
last season also people did play and put
you know a lot into it
just get out what they put in and that
way maybe the next
season we can really start fresh and
there can be fans in the stands
and we can just like finish out this
weird season in this weird way well so
then like with the bubble so everyone's
basically in orlando but there is a
basketball team
in orlando and i'm like do the orlando
magics have to like
stay down the road from like their
actual house or like can they go home
and they can't go home yeah it's not
weird
i mean it's weird but i that's that's
the point of the bubble right and it's
effective because then ben was also
telling me that the mlb is having
baseball is having a lot of trouble
because 13 marlins players got
coronavirus
because they're not in the bubble yeah
because there is no bubble for for
right now but there should be i think
it's a good idea yeah i think everything
is is a good idea
try it see how it works we need
solutions yep
ben said though that the food in the
bubble is not good and a lot of the
players are complaining about it
that's that's a big issue yeah and i was
saying i'm like is it luxurious like
these are guys who make like 50 million
dollars a year like
they live in mansions like you can't
just throw them in a hotel room for six
months like
it's gotta be nice i would love to know
some more about like the actual digs
like
do people is it all in a hotel do they
get like little cottages like what's it
like
yeah but there's a lot of players so
yeah can't all be so
and they're huge like they literally
can't stand like a standard holiday inn
you know
yeah but that's like when they go to the
super bowl too yeah they stay in hotels
yeah that's true i guess i don't know it
is interesting
yeah i would like an architectural
digest like on the living quarters in
the bubble
yeah well it also is probably similar to
the olympic village
you know yeah hopefully not the one in
uh sochi but i don't think the olympic
village is particularly glamorous but a
lot of
you know mega stars and talents go there
that's true
so you do it for the love of the craft
yes that's true
the love of sports we love sports so
much i mean
and that was your sports news for the
day thank you guys so much and that
sports news segment was brought to you
by liquid iv
perfect believe it or not dehydration
occurs daily in three out of four people
with liquid iv you have the fastest most
efficient way to stay hydrated
each serving helps you get as much
hydration as two to three bottles of
water
if you have trouble drinking water it's
like not something i can really like on
a realistic level do
and if you watch my comedy special you
would know that i drink a lot of water
thank you
and liquid iv and pouring liquid iv in
your water like literally makes you it's
just it's time management you know it
multiplies
the effect proper hydration is crucial
for your immune system because it can
boost your immunity
and everyone needs that right now with
liquid iv you have the fastest most
efficient way to stay hydrated plus it's
backed with potassium vitamin c and
other vitamins known to help your body
defend against against infections one
serving of liquid iv
provides the same hydration as drinking
two to three bottles of water alone
contain it contains five essential
vitamins more vitamin c than an orange
and as much potassium as a banana
it's healthier than other sugary sports
drinks it has no artificial flavors or
preservatives
and it has less sugar than an apple what
makes it so effective is their ctt
cellular transport technology which is
the optimal ratio of glucose
sodium and potassium delivering
nutrients straight into your bloodstream
through the water
it's a perfect balance to help you
hydrate more quickly and effectively
than water alone
one stick of liquid iv and 16 ounces of
water can give you as much hydration as
two to three
bottles of plain water plus liquid iv is
on a mission to change the world
liquid iv is donating 2.3 million
servings in response to cobit 19
products are being donated to hospitals
first responders food banks veterans and
active military
liquid iv is available nationwide at
costco and target or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidity.com and use
the code toast at checkout
that's 25 off anything you order when
you use promo code toast at liquid
iv.com get better hydration today
liquidive.com
promo code toast plus if you like to
drink
like i do liquid iv although it's not
really what they're marketing it's
fabulous for hangovers because it's
really hard to drink water when you're
hungover liquidity just gives you two to
three bottles of water and 16 ounces
yeah it's it's the stuff okay next story
really sad kim kardashian was spotted
with kanye west in wyoming after his
apology
kim and kanye are talking things out the
long time couple reunited for the first
time in recent weeks
on monday july 27th in photos obtained
by tmz
the pair was spotted driving together in
wyoming a source tells e-news it got
very emotional
if you haven't seen these photos yet
it's clear that it's emotional
kim looks to be crying kanye looks to be
talking passionately if you haven't seen
these photos it's because i made the
decision not to post them on our
instagram
um they're so invasive personal yeah and
they're certain like we were talking
about this with naya rivera um
where like at certain times like the
media just doesn't respect boundaries
and
and i know that kim you know signed up
for this life and like really has put it
all out there
um i don't know i just i feel like i'm
hyper sensitive to this these days
and it all really started of those
paparazzi pictures of bethany at
dennis's private burial funeral um
were taken because paparazzi were like
hiding in the bushes in a [ __ ]
cemetery in new jersey like
that really set off this thing in me
where it's like i find it so offensive
and inappropriate
and the fact that nobody like knows
where to cross a line
yeah i agree that these photos are
invasive but no one
died these these are just celebrities
and and kim and kanye are the biggest
stars in the world so i under like and
i i disagree i think that they are
too personal but i we also have like a a
boundary level that i guess
most outlets or celebrities don't or
celebrity news outlets don't have
yes no i know nobody died that's not
what i was saying i'm saying i think it
falls under the same category of like
why why must the media and paparazzi
like push so much like
and the fact that like somebody captured
this photo and instead of like feeling
bad about it like literally
ran to sell it that's just so [ __ ] i
can't even imagine how much money they
made
no i am probably the most a photo has
made in a very long time no 100 i mean i
don't even know the last time i saw kim
kardashian cry especially like
she volunteers not ourselves yes yeah no
and we know the kim crying face and i
find it to be really heartbreaking
i know there's it was just like
obviously so much like pain in that car
like i don't even
know what part they were dressing i
don't even know what part she's crying
about
maybe she's crying wanting him to get
help
it's just it's too much you know it's
too much
and i just feel really sad about this
whole thing and like
i really hate reporting on it it makes
me really sad yeah
and i hate to see him cry and i hated
those pictures
yeah but i also saw a picture of them
looking fine in the back of that car
also
they went to wendy's yes i wonder what
they got i love how much kim
loves fast food like on the most recent
um season of kardashians when she was in
houston um a meeting with
someone from her you know uh law firm
group
and they stopped at mcdonald's and got a
mcflurry like that was the best moment
of my life like celebrities are just
like us they eat like [ __ ]
oh my god that was the best moment of
reality television and then like the
women behind the counter were just like
dying like i watch you every week it was
so cute it was so cute
so that's the latest with kim and kanye
they're reunited
yeah i'm glad that they're together and
they're talking face-to-face
and i thought the public apology was
sort of closing the book on this
on this matter but um i'm sure it's far
from over i'm sure
yeah okay next story some really crazy
news the ellen degeneres show is
reportedly under internal investigation
after workplace complaints ellen
degeneres acclaimed talk show is
reportedly under internal
review following multiple allegations
from former staffers about the talk
show's workplace environment
according to reports from variety the
hollywood reporter both published monday
the ellen degeneres show will undergo an
internal investigation by warner media
reps for the ellen degeneres show and
warner brothers television declined to
comment written reached by people
a rep for degeneres did not immediately
return people's request for comment
seems like everyone's crawling back into
their cabinets now that the
accountability coach is here
yeah you know what was the story that we
just reported on ellen last week
something about the three producers like
that no
um [ __ ] i forget
but like i feel like this investigation
it gives those conspiracies
we spoke about the conspiracy theories
oh yeah but it's not an investigation by
the police it's by warner media so it's
like
it's like an interior i feel like
honestly it's probably not even real
it's just to appease like the constant
fodder on like twitter and social media
of people just like coming for ellen
it's like there's been so many news
articles
um since quarantine started that like
they've just been completely ignoring
like ellen has not addressed
any of this ones she didn't address the
first wave of news which is that she's
the meanest woman alive
a quote from someone who wasn't me um
she's the meanest woman alive
and then there was the other wave of
like an internal investigation all those
three producers were so mean and created
this culture
of like nastiness and like high school
vibes
and none of that has been addressed by
anyone i actually went on um andy
lassner's twitter last night because
he's always tweeting like
he tweets like 500 times a day he's like
a lot of followers not
one word on the matter he hasn't tweeted
since he like tweeted something about
ellen's dog who died
sad for the dog sad for the dog yeah i
guess this is in response to all of the
stories and allegations that have come
forward and this is what they have to do
and
i'm glad because i feel like all this
stuff has been coming out and there's
like no response no repercussions like
there's nothing
yeah so i don't know what a
international investigation whatever
media can do right like what is actually
going to come from this
spotlights on them yeah i'd just be very
interested like when they're back in
studio like
i don't know i feel like ellen's never
really gone through her controversy
because she's always been like
america's sweetheart like a gay icon and
i feel like she's never like had to come
on her show and like address something
or apologize you know
yeah but speaking of going back to the
studio um for
like people in l.a and hollywood and do
they have plans
to go back la is in pretty like new york
and la were i think
and on the same level for a while with
the coronavirus and
i think new york handled it better
because we seem to be in phase four and
i think they're
like still on lockdown um but i've been
seeing celebrities stepping out and
stuff
yeah but like i don't think that they're
even close to where we they regressed
a bit right so i i don't know i wonder
if like andy cohen
like new york-based jimmy fallon if
they'll even
because we're ahead of most other states
as far as i know
we don't feel ahead no we don't but we i
think we technically are
got it okay well fifth and final story
an answer to yesterday's question i
think the kissing booth three was filmed
in secret to keep teen romance alive
just [ __ ] cares well i'm like i'm
really getting like i'm sorry it's
starting to
actually do you think this is an
interesting tactic and i think it
explains why it took so long for kissing
with two to come out because they filmed
two movies
they filmed two to all the boys i loved
before too
they did yeah at the same time oh so we
should be getting two teen
hits very soon i just
part of me i don't know why he's like so
bothered by this franchise like it it's
really like triggering me
i don't think i'm gonna watch the second
movie because i don't want to feel how
you feel
no i know it's very disappointing like i
was already like
after the first one and then my whole
journey i spoke about i'm not going into
it again with all the boys i loved
before
i was already like over the franchise
and then with the second movie i
actually read a spoiler of what ends up
happening
and it's so outrageously unrealistic
like i
can't really like with the colleges oh
does she get it wait spoilers
does she get into harvard she gets
hold on you know what i actually don't
even remember it was so dumb it's like
she gets wait listed
where she gets in and but doesn't tell
anyone and then the movie ends like what
the [ __ ]
yeah it's so dumb i understand your
frustration i'm taking it off my list of
things i'm going to watch you know
because i would just like to leave it at
what i thought it was
a beautiful love story between two kids
in love falling in love in real life and
you know what they don't ultimately work
out and i think that also is
what would have happened in the first
movie of course but
they gave it their all they gave it
their all and that's all that matters
but i do like this strategy of filming
two movies at once because kissing booth
3
was secretly shot at the same time as
the sequel so filming is already
complete it's currently in
post-production
and will premiere on netflix in 2021 oh
another complaint i had against the
kissing booth that i actually
when i re-watched yesterday's show i
realized i forgot to mention
is that you know the first movie it's
all set in la but they film in south
africa
and i feel like in the first movie they
try to you know really hide that they
were in south africa
and and in the second movie it just
became so much less believable that they
were
not in south africa like literally like
that they weren't they were not in l.a
yeah and that they were in south africa
like literally like
she opens her window in her house and
there's like a jungle like it's just it
was
so south africa got it i was just not
buying anything they were telling me i i
understand
i understand i won't bring it up again i
was only able to spend disbelief for so
long
i think we might have to china the
kissing franchise
because look what it's doing to me of
what it's done to you
look what it's doing and like honestly
the only thing that could send me over
the edge even more is like if we got a
sierra burgess is a loser sequel because
that movie
that movie was not only terrible but
like really unethical
i completely agree we went in on it on
the show i remember because i remember
just being so
taken aback by how dumb it was
and what a bad message it sent to
children yeah
i completely agree please don't give us
a sequel
not that i heard any rumors no no and i
don't want to drudge up like
i don't want to put it out into the
universe yeah and manifest it let me
just grab that right back and put it in
my pocket we're good
we're good um okay tv recap really
quickly i just wanted to say i started
the new season of shameless
which is a show that i just watched when
it's on netflix and it's really mindless
and
and really fun to watch um but this is
the first season without fiona gallagher
played by emmy rossum it's like this is
the show that made her and then she
decided to leave
um and i just want to say like kudos to
emmy ross i'm like
she knew like the only way the show
could get better is if she left and i'm
so glad she's gone like
she was my absolutely favorite character
and they're
so the family's so big so like it's one
of those shows where it's like you get a
couple minutes of everyone every episode
and fiona was like to me the worst and
least interesting and got the most
screen time so now it's like there's
more parts of the episode dedicated to
lip who's my favorite and ian and debbie
and it's like everyone has
more time because they're not being
bogged down by fiona and her poor
decision making
and i just think the show is i thought
it was obviously going to be the end of
shameless like without fiona but it's
just
absolutely fabulous like i can't
recommend it enough wow that's so great
to hear i thought you were going to say
you wanted to congratulate her because
she got out
you know at the right time no no it was
getting a little stale and it needed to
be shaken up and i just didn't realize
the main character leaving would be the
thing to shake it up
because usually that's the thing that
breaks it 100 marissa cooper
it's just it's a totally different show
and i'm enjoying it so much more
wow that's so great to hear yeah and you
know season 10 of a show
it's like that's crazy let's let's kill
they shoot horses don't they but it's
really they do on yellowstone oh do they
um oh not gratuitously but if a horse
know if i can handle that if a horse is
dying you know if they if the horse
found itself in a
precarious situation they'll put it out
of its misery what kind of situation is
this horse finding himself
um well in the opening scene which isn't
the spoiler no no the first scene
i don't want you to turn it on i don't
hear if you're gonna make me watch it
like i don't want it okay
okay okay okay yeah
but there's not a lot of horse abuse
because i can't handle that i love the
horses
the horses are treated with love and
respect i know and then part of me like
maybe i'm getting two in the weeds like
part of me is just like an animal lover
i hate watching shows that even have
animals in it because it's like what is
that animal doing on a set
i hear you but if you see the sets like
i think it
they're a wonderful place for an animal
to grow up and i think the show really
is about
the land in yellowstone and the beauty
and and the animals
and the wildlife that live there and i
think it's really i i understand are
they being paid
the animals yeah no their owners are
capitalizing
animals are not entertainment see i
actually i really don't like when shows
even have a dog
not to get on my soapbox but yeah i just
what is that dog doing on a set
he should be in a park he's making he's
working hard no but he didn't
consent to his owner is just like you
know
selling him for a quick buck but you
couldn't make that argument about
anything that dogs do that they don't
consent to
no because that dog doing on a set
oh my god you're right
i'm so embarrassed i can't but like he's
so happy look at him
but he's not working he's working you
know what they do to those animals on
set you ever see that video
from that stupid dennis quaid movie with
all the dogs when the dog is drowning a
dog's purpose
but people only tune into this show to
watch thgo sleep
i can't believe you just called me out
like so hard i didn't realize that
that's where this was going but like it
was
right there this is not a real set like
this is the living room
i i agree and if and i wouldn't have a
problem if
a dog was brought onto a movie set to
sleep but that's not what they're doing
they're like
making them like you know do weird
tricks and like move this way and i
don't know i just don't like it
okay okay so then you might actually not
like the show but give it a chance or
what are the horses the main character
on yellowstone
they're in pretty much every scene
they're cowboys that's gonna be tough
for me
they're cowboys it's really tough for me
to drive by the park and see those poor
horses being just like okay but those
horses are out of their element and
these horses are very much in their
elements yes
on the show but they're out of their
element on the set it's very
metaphysical but the set
is i believe it's filmed in utah and
that's if i were a horse that's where
i'd want to be
even as a person if i was a human that's
why i'd wanted me even though
all this drama with kim and kanye is
really making me want to move to cody
yeah it's really great publicity for the
state of wyoming even though i'm sure
they don't see it that way
no not at all stunning though yeah
sickening see
just like yellowstone theo heard about
the abuse and he's on his way to file
he has agency what do you where do you
want to go what do you want to do you
want to go back to sleep
do you want to walk out the door this is
your life theo
you're living it i love you you look so
happy come
on oh well that's all i had to say i'm
sure
i'm halfway through the redheads book
where i heard it's very dark
it's very dark it's very intense but
it's a very good
book but it's a lot we're recording it
next week instead of the end of this
week but the episode will still be out
at the same time so it gives us a little
bit more time to read it
and if you guys have questions you can
always email the redheads
redheadsbookclub gmail.com
questions about the book questions about
other books that we read questions you
want them to answer an address on the
show
i'm just so emotional talking about
their heads that's what a passion
project will do to you
yeah i'm just so passionate about it
speaking of passion projects we have so
many fabulous tnn shows that are just
turning out premium content right now
i mean margaret joseph has been locked
up in our house in new jersey
non-stop turning out content they moved
to two episodes a week and then they
started
doing it on video and they have gotten
some amazing guests and they also just
did an episode with carson kressley who
was like a mainstay judge on
rupaul's drag race which is was a
fabulous episode and he was just on
real housewives of new york no that is
um another carson carson
oh no colin cowie yeah yeah yeah yeah i
thought you're gonna take colleen
kaepernick i'm like no i don't think
that was good
um yeah colin cowie but they've gotten
fabulous fabulous episodes um
lauren has a ton of new podcast episodes
she just did one with emma ledger who's
like literally the fastest growing
instagram fashion blogger and got all of
her tips and tricks her instagram is
sickening
so if you want some tips and tricks head
over to mood with lauren elizabeth it
was really good and then oh
raven and alexis did a fabulous episode
of girls night with danielle lombard and
jasmine good from their season and
they're just
they're really like best best friends
and it was the
funniest episode alexis is so funny and
her and raven together are not that
raven and adam weren't a great podcast
duo but the
alexis just brings out like a crazy side
and raven she brings out a crazy side in
everyone it truly feels like a girls
night
that's what it is and that episode was
really good along with a bunch of other
episodes that they've done so
if you're done here and you've done
listening to all of our patreon episodes
head over to toast news network you can
follow us on instagram for updates on
all the new tnn shows
new episodes from all of our shows are
dropping consistently every week the
snatcher is going to be back
next month when claire returns to the
screen
is claire in a bubble right now too i
believe they are in like a hotel in
mexico in a bubble i think it's probably
the same premise
just no one's really talking about it
that the fact that they're filming right
yeah
but that's exciting that they're filming
and it's exciting that the snatcher's
coming and
hopefully they found a way to film
safely and maybe other shows could
replicate that you know hopefully
so and that the snatcher is coming back
i missed that snatcher i missed that
snatcher too and i hope she learned her
lesson
i don't think that she did though that's
that is probably the first thing she'll
cover on the episode back um that's it
you guys that's all she wrote thank you
guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we go live monday through
friday 10 30 amy oh
[ __ ] it's all right take it from the top
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast milania morning show
where
we post live it's okay
take three thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennium morning show we post videos
on our youtube channel monday through
friday and we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast can be found
spotify itunes stitcher public radio ir
radio cast box
all the places plus you can now listen
to our podcasts and watch our videos on
spotify which we are so excited to
now have our videos be uploaded to
spotify anytime anywhere you listen to
your podcast please find us the morning
toast and leave a five star review about
a beautiful
stunning smart and charming we are
yeah and charming uh we hope you guys
have a fabulous day we'll see you
tomorrow for hump day
[Music]
goodbye
you